good morning Hank it's Tuesday so you
know the Obamacare insurance exchanges
that depending on your political
perspective are either the cause of or
the solution to so many of America's
health care problems only about 6% of
Americans actually get their insurance
through those exchanges now that's
obviously very important to those six
percent of people but it's by far the
smallest slice of the American health
insurance pie and I think the relentless
focus on them in our political discourse
speaks to a larger inability to have for
lack of a better phrase a grown up
conversation about health care
okay so health care is very complicated
and I'm gonna paint this in the broadest
possible strokes if you want far more
information about health and health care
please check out healthcare triage but
let's start with what health insurance
does health insurance takes money from
healthy people and uses it to buy care
for sick people you can do this through
private insurance which pulls people
together and takes money from them in
the form of monthly premiums or you can
do it through a public insurer which
pulls people together and takes money
from them in the form of taxes in the
United States we have both almost
everyone over the age of 65 is in this
publicly funded insurance pool called
Medicare many military veterans are in a
similar pool run by the Veterans
Administration and there's a third
publicly funded pool that covers many
low-income and disabled Americans called
Medicaid but just over half of Americans
get their insurance through private
insurers this includes the six percent
of people who are covered through the
Obamacare exchanges but mostly people
who get their insurance from their
employers because large companies are
required to offer health insurance plans
to their employees then you have the
nine percent of Americans who don't have
any health insurance at all that number
has dropped a lot in the last five years
but it's still higher than any other
wealthy nation so the current US health
care system is widely considered to be
if I can use a technical term bananas we
spend so so much on health care about
18% of our total economic output goes to
health care the average among other
wealthy nations is closer to 12% and we
also don't get particularly good health
care outcomes like we come up short in
many many metrics including life
expectancy where we trail countries like
Chile and Slovenia both of which spend
less than 10 percent of their GDP on
health care and for the record both of
which also have higher rates of tobacco
usage now you would think with lots of
private participation in health care
markets costs would be driven down right
like private companies can make
refrigerators or cars much better than
governments can make refrigerators or
cars but health care is a weird market
on a few levels first there's the
problem of inelastic demand
if I need a medicine to keep me alive I
can't effectively negotiate the price of
that medication because in the end I'm
gonna pay whatever it costs and then
there's the problem of competition being
something of an illusion like for
instance if you're having a heart attack
it's generally not considered a good
idea to call around to a bunch of area
hospitals to find out who has the best
deal on heart surgery this week
there should be competition among
private insurers but plans are often
extremely confusing like you might pay
less upfront and think you're getting a
good deal only to find out later that
what you need to be covered isn't
covered like it's hard to compare
cellphone plans effectively let alone
health insurance plans that might or
might not cover literally thousands of
different procedures plus having your
insurance status depend partly on
whether you work for a big company is a
huge disincentive to innovation and
entrepreneurship it tells people don't
start a new business don't strike out on
your own because you won't be able to
get affordable health insurance so owe
it all we've ended up with a health care
system where more tax dollars per person
go to publicly funded health care than
in most other countries and yet we don't
have publicly funded health care for
most people and most Americans agree on
this only about 32 percent of us think
that our health care system is good or
excellent and yet around 70 percent of
Americans think that their personal
health care is good or excellent and
therein lies the problem most serious
reform proposals would involve big
changes for many people in that seventy
percent and as the Republican Party has
lately learned it's easy to talk about
health care reform in the abstract but
when you put pen to paper it gets
complicated
so all health care reform boils down to
three factors quality cost and access
Obama care sought to improve access it
didn't do much to change quality or cost
and to do that it spent a huge amount of
money like a trillion dollars in the
first decade now it increased some taxes
and cut some spending so as to be
deficit-neutral but it spent a lot of
money to get a lot of people health
insurance so today fewer people are
uninsured but it cost a lot to get there
that was the trade-off the Republican
bill sought to reduce government
spending on health care but that also
comes with trade-offs in this case it
would have resulted in millions of
people losing their insurance which was
a hard sell to moderate Republicans so
the GOP bill offered tax credits to help
people buy private insurance but that
meant more spending which made it a hard
sell to conservative Republicans like
the ACA itself the GOP bill would not
have done a lot to address the overall
cost of health care in the United States
or the fact
our quality of care isn't great because
to have those conversations we need to
accept that as healthcare triage always
says trade offs are inevitable side note
I just realized that my collar is turned
so I fixed that but I bet it was
annoying to a lot of you sorry
right so the most commonly cited
solution to the u.s. healthcare problem
is a single-payer health care system or
Medicare for all of us Bernie Sanders
calls it in this proposal all Americans
would be able to get the kind of
publicly funded insurance that seniors
now get and studies have shown that this
would lower overall u.s. health care
costs although probably not to the rate
seen in most European countries still
there would be less money spent on
administration and advertising and also
on care itself because a bigger
insurance pool can negotiate prices more
aggressively and this would be like a
huge insurance pool but there are
trade-offs like it's accurate to say
that Medicare for all would lower
overall US health care costs it's also
accurate to say that it would cost
hundreds of thousands of jobs and many
of them would be good-paying jobs from
medical device sales people to insurance
adjusters to marketing managers and with
less money being spent per procedure
lots of other people would see their
incomes go down including many doctors
and nurses also it would be good to
spend 12 percent of our GDP on health
care instead of 18 percent if we could
get similar outcomes but there is a word
for what happens when six percent of
your total economy goes away overnight
recession now the economy would recover
and reallocate capital fairly quickly
but it wouldn't be painless it's also
important to note that we currently have
a single-payer health care system in the
United States in Medicare and it's not a
bargain compared to other single-payer
systems around the world it's very
expensive because we resist the kind of
government regulations and price
controls that are ultimately necessary
to rein in spending so a single-payer
system on its own would not solve all of
our problems and there would be
trade-offs alternately some on the right
have argued that to increase competition
and that market forces work it's
necessary to dramatically scale back or
even eliminate government funding for
health care and that too might lower
prices but at the cost of many millions
of people losing insurance
similarly decreasing regulation might
lower prices but it increases the risks
of being treated by an inadequately
trained professional or taking an unsafe
medication trade-offs we can talk about
over-regulation or tort reform or
marketplaces or competition but none of
them will be a magic bullet because
there is no magical solution with our
health care system where every
wins and no one loses now we can
continue to make incremental changes
like the ACA or alternatives to it but
as dr. Carroll put it on Twitter however
you want to reform health care there
will be trade-offs those who promise you
everything are lying if we want a better
healthcare system in the United States
we need to talk openly about those
trade-offs because when we allow
ourselves to be pandered to our elected
leaders seem more than happy to oblige
us Hank I'll see you on Friday